[Music]
parents are finding new ways to express
their frustration over remote learning
in arizona a new billboard demands
students get back to the classroom
reading quote tempe union high school
district is failing our kids open our
schools
our next guest has a teenager with
autism in the district and says his
community just wants what is best for
their children
john led joins us now john thanks for
being with us this morning
so when you saw that billboard what did
you think
i was shocked i couldn't believe that
somebody had
first of all spent the money to do it
and then also got so
frustrated with the lack of
communication and a plan
that that's the measure they took
do you think it was effective in
actually changing policy seeing
something like that
well it's hard to say if it's a
coincidence or not but within 24 hours
our superintendent was
adamant that he wanted kids back in
school and within 48 hours
we actually had an email from the
district stating we will be in person on
march 15th
wow so maybe maybe it had an effect
maybe it didn't but it's certainly quite
a billboard
you know it's been challenging in tempe
it's gone from virtual
to hybrid and then there was a covet
outbreak and then back to virtual
there is a statement from tempe union
high school from the district we want to
read it and get your response to it it
says bringing students back is what we
have been working on
and planning for throughout the pandemic
we certainly value input from our
families parents and other stakeholders
but ultimately
this billboard seems to seek to be a
divisive distraction we remain 100
focused on getting our students back to
school safely what are your thoughts on
that statement as a parent
um well our neighboring districts in
chandler gilbert mesa have all been in
school
the majority of the school year they've
seemed to find a way to navigate it and
give parents the option of being online
or in person
and that's all we're really looking for
is i think we deserve the same option in
our community as our neighboring
communities
now your son is a sophomore how has he
done with the remote learning
uh there have been some challenges for
sure i know i probably end up calling
them six to eight times a day to check
in
make sure everything's okay a lot of
technology of course it ended up popping
up
uh he's overall excelling in the
classroom
um it has been a little challenging
though trying to
make sure that he's staying on top of
his work make sure he's being able to be
logged into the classes
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
that
you know i'm sure you spent a lot of
time talking to other parents in the
community
in general do you feel that most parents
want their kids back in school
are any hesitant what is the general
feeling right now in your community
about returning to school
in person full-time there's definitely a
split
there are people that are just better
staying at home they stay for the rest
of the year they want to do the online
thing
and then there's a large group that are
seeing their kids suffer or seeing their
kids fully withdraw
i've had friends that who have had you
know children trying to
slit their wrists because they were so
unhappy uh there's a lot of parents
saying their kids are showing grades
that they've never seen from their kids
before getting d's and f's
when they were typically honorable
students so there is a divide on that
but that's why we're wanting the options
we want people that
feel they need their kid in person for
their kid to be successful
to have that option and then of course
the people that feel they're
they're safer at home give them the
option of doing online learning
yeah you know john i think that's an
important point that you bring to life
that much like adults
kids are different they're all different
some thrive in certain environments
others don't so this has been a
challenging time for us all hopefully
the kids get back to school can do so
safely for the kids for the teachers we
loved having you here today and thank
you for being here with us